let's just go right to the John Kennedy
so he is a republican from Louisiana
we've played a couple clips of this
guy's just got a great way with words
and how to he's just got like just a
perfect quip on almost everything and
one of the few sane DC politicians and
here he is talking about the Omnibus
Bill this is the 1.7 trillion dollar
bill that's sort of being attached to
this zelenski thing right because within
the 1.7 trillion is the extra 40 billion
for this guy and again don't forget the
you know 68 roughly billion that we've
already given him here's John Kennedy
I've been given two choices
door number one is the current budget
proposals put together by uh Senator
McConnell Senator Schumer speaker Pelosi
uh it's about 133 percent no strike that
it's about a 33 percent increase over
pre-pandemic spending uh the three
people who put it together say it's the
best they can do
but there's a door number two door
number two is to wait
for a republican House of
Representatives and allow the the House
Republicans to put together a bill as a
starting point now you don't basically
that would substitute McCarthy for
Pelosi in terms of putting together a
budget bill you don't have to be a
a senior at Caltech to figure out if
your objective is fiscal restraint
you're better off with McCarthy than
Pelosi
we have a lot of big government
Republicans and we have a lot of
Ritz-Carlton Democrats in this Congress
and most of them don't believe that the
spending makes any difference
in terms of the America's economy and
our attempt to reduce inflation now I
don't agree with them
um
I think those who believe that
were probably in the quad playing
frisbee during econ 101 but we're going
to find out because I think this budget
that they put together is uh is going to
pass
okay so first the end yeah this thing's
gonna pass it's just gonna pass this is
how it works they scare the hell out of
everybody they jam it through by sending
it to people at 2 A.M on a Tuesday night
they know no one's read it 4 200 pages
of this literally nobody's read it they
lie about when people got the
information they have insane amounts of
pork in there for crazy funding of
insane things including further funding
of the NIH and all of the stuff that has
done all of the bad stuff and they just
keep doing it but at the very least
what Kennedy said there is right at the
very least so so we're on the the 22nd
today is December 22nd so about nine
days left in this year rolling into
Christmas all the Republicans would have
to do right now is demand with with
whatever power they have they could in
essence say listen we're not signing
this thing we're just not signing this
thing what we're going to do is we'll
agree to fund the government for the
rest of the year so that we have a
government over Christmas I don't know
what the government's doing but okay
let's have a government over Christmas
honestly the biggest Christmas gift to
me would be that we wouldn't have a
government that would be of absolute
pleasure I guess I've become an
anarchist here
um but what the Republicans should be
doing this is what he is saying and this
is exactly by the way what McCarthy said
yesterday because McCarthy is about to
be the leader of the house right he's
taking over for Pelosi as Kennedy said
you fund the government to the end of
the year and then now that the
Republicans are in charge it's not that
they're going to be that great they will
not be that great right you don't have
to be a republican but you cannot be a
Democrat that's what I always say they
will not be that great they will fail
you blah blah blah but fun the thing to
the end of the year then when
Republicans take over then how about we
rewrite a more sensible bill and we cut
some of the pork and maybe I don't know
could uh you think zelenski would be
okay if we gave him say I don't know 30
instead of 38 billion you think he'd be
okay could we get some receipts on any
of this stuff